Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie new walking dead
let's break it down, teasing a new group.
So I'm going to explain the whisperers along
with this new group because I don't think
it's the whisperers, but I do think that we'll
see them eventually we are the saviors we
bring civilization to the people I love the
Negan brainwashing scene here this is just
him holding court with the saviors Daryl standing
there in the crowd we're just getting to see
a little bit more of their culture.
We also see Spencer here at the Safe Zone
treating with them he's still kind of a douche
bag but he had that brief end tag with Rosita
about fighting back so I don't necessarily
think that he's going to cross the aisle and
join the saviors or anything like that that.
It would be a WTF twist so maybe if we see
something from him like that that he'll be
something of a double agent.
But they wouldn't put this scene in the trailer
randomly.
So this is going to be some important moment
for next week's episode, we finally catch
up with Tara who runs into another group with
Heath, which I'll talk about in just a second,
I know it seems like the whisperers, but even
though we are going to get to them eventually.
I don't think that's who that is there's a
bunch of other small groups that the comic
books can introduce when Morgan and Carol
are here at the Kingdom talking about not
being able to trust them.
I think they want you to think they're talking
about the saviors, but I think that they been
teasing another group showing up so they might
be talking about another group I like the
only other group besides the survivors that
we've interacted with at the kingdom is the
saviors.
So you to the just like broadening the dynamic
here and just hammers home the idea of them
fracturing the group the survivors into a
bunch of different places this season, but
that gives you the opportunity like with Tara
storyline next week to meet another new group.
So then you have Rick and Aaron who also look
like they're going to run into another new
group, but I would be surprised if there's
some convergence here like you see Tara running
into the same people that Rick and Aaron do.
But I think the next new community were going
to meet from the comics is going to be Oceanside
which is not the whisperers, but they don't
debut in the comics till much later.
So whoever they're introducing from the comics.
They would still have to move up that revealed
because there some storylines that there speeding
through.
But then there's the Carl stuff that we learned
about this past week.
So some storylines moving slowly like Carl
summer moving a little bit faster like meeting
other new people see you guys can let me know
in the comics like which new group do you
think it is that they're going to be running
into, but the thing about the whispers is
they actually debuted before Oceanside, but
the whispers are like their such a big group
that I think the gonna try and hold off as
long as possible but for all the comic book
readers out there who are trying to plot the
season out in their head just based on how
fast are movie they did him to expect them
before.
Most people were expecting them to show up
so the big thing about the whispers of their
hard-core in the camo that they wear has like
a really special twist that I'll say for their
actual debut.
But if you read the comics then obviously
you know exactly what's going on it just the
way that they operate the techniques that
they use that you know just like the characters
themselves are just so much more hard-core
than what we seen before.
Not hardcore like Negan is a psychopath hardcore
but just the links that they're willing to
go to to survive.
So when you hear people talk about alpha and
beta like can't wait for Alf to show up there
talking about the whispers she is like the
leader of that group when they first meet
them.
So remains to be seen when that's can happen,
but because were only an episode six I still
think it's gonna be a while before we see
them so that would mean that this new group
we meet in episode six is somebody else.
So get hype if you felt like this past episode
was a little slow.
I feel like this is the answer to that they
kinda been doing that the season with it like
really big sprawling episode with a bunch
of crazy action than they have an episode
to just relatively self-contained with fewer
characters little bit quieter and they go
back to super crazy.
So if you guys want I'll still do that Carl
Grimes rumor video but it is a rumor and it
could be potentially spoiler he depending
on whether or not it's true.
So I am hesitant to do it but if you guys
want me to just let me know in the comments
I'll say congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Elliott McDonald you and a $20 Amazon
gift card be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details the next round of the giveaway
will start when I post my next walking dead
video there is some cool, comic book cyborg
Superman stuff happening later tonight so
there might be a 3rd video for Cyborg Superman.
While you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for this week's Walking Dead episode
and you can click here for this week's Westworld.
Thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you guys tonight!